foreign
which is what's the one thing we're not
talking about as a society but we really
should be
this is going to be a controversial one
I don't know if I should really say it
you're going to mess up the the
optimistic note that we tried to end on
hmm
that's a good question I think it's that
thing oh boy
um the class divide
never gets discussed they're gonna have
to cut this right this is something that
people will not talk about and they were
beating each other with pillows in there
bro and I sat out there and watched
smoke the cigarette out there well you
should be talking about my books
while there's too many goddamn people uh
well you know well we're not talking
about dads is the horrible way in which
we allow the car to dominate our
civilization I'm gonna I'm going to
introduce something now which you might
find a little bit uncomfortable the
thing that pisses me off oh my goodness
um I think we're not talking enough
about sex so I would love to talk to you
about lots of things to be offended is
not something that anyone need or should
respect my answer to that is
really mundane
uh I think it's constants baldness
what's the one thing we're not talking
about that we really should be
I'm gonna mess up the the optimistic
note that we tried to end on sex robots
any sex robots are on their way I think
they shouldn't be and I think there's a
very light Pro male reason to say that
they shouldn't be I mean the concern for
sex about sex robots has generally been
for a feminist perspective the idea that
you're kind of training
um men who use them to think of women as
being an inert and whatever like
encouraging violence I'm sure that's
probably true
for me though I think the problem one of
the really big problems for sex robots
as well as that is that
you've got
skyrocketing about some young men who
are not having sex relationships at all
who are going into their 20s or even 30s
remaining virgins hooked on Pawn you
know all of this
and more than that also just not living
productive lives you know not holding
down jobs not like not making any
progress in their lives
um just stuck in this kind of miserable
adolescence and I think sex robots would
just supercharge that if they ever
became you know affordable for these men
and became
um like sufficiently convincing which
they are on track to because what what
sex robots basically do to the like
to the monkey brain you know to the
evolved mind is they is they give you a
completely false sense of like your own
success in the world you can be
you know you don't have to go to the gym
you don't have to clean your room you
don't have to have a job you don't have
to own a house you don't have to do any
of the things that will actually make
you a happier and more enriched human
being because you've got your sex robot
who will give you the impression that
actually you're a starred
and I think that there's a it's like
super stimuli
times a million right this ex robot is
like the most the most perfect
encapsulation of that of that phenomenon
and that risk and yeah I think that we
need to
I think we need to ban them basically
like whatever mechanism is necessary why
aren't we talking about de-extinction
more do you know about de-extinction no
the idea that we could it makes far
worse Rebellion the extinction Rebellion
everything's fine there's more species
again yeah that's right what is the
extinction the the extinction is simply
bringing back the mammoth or bringing
back the passenger pigeon or the great
orc you know something that's gone
extinct
four steps read The genome done that in
lots of these cases here we've got
ancient DNA from samples we know what
the Genome of these creatures looks like
second
take a living genome from a related
species and edit it so it's the same
third somehow get that into a living
creature don't turn that cell into a
embryo and then into a creature and
fourth release it to the one fantastic
so not only are we getting the pandemic
we're getting Jurassic Park as well
perfect
it's important for everyone to know if
they don't already if it last decade
didn't get it through uh that even in
the UK we are now living in an
environment of mass electronic
surveillance
um and our own government spy on us what
does that mean practically when you say
Mass electronic surveillance is your
phone listening to you right now
um the government collects and can
collect and access uh calls video calls
texts messages they can hack devices
they can hack entire nations
devices if they want to we have we have
the most totalitarian surveillance
legislation of any democracy in the
world in the UK and some of the most uh
Advanced capabilities we've seen over
the last few decades
um how you've had environmental
activists racer quality campaigners
um environmentalists being spied on
um by by their own government and and
sometimes with with very negative
impacts
um that is a big chunk of the battle
that we have to fight and I would like
to see a bit more uh that to kind of
register on the political Spectrum a bit
more
um but meanwhile I would say to everyone
use signal
the class divide
never gets discussed
you know we talk about divisions in
society we talk about you know ethnicity
constantly are we being fair to this
group of people or that group of people
far too little discussion on social
Mobility
um and and actually
what I see is the more governments tax
and redistribute
the lower levels of social Mobility are
for social Mobility people need
opportunity they need that through
education which I mentioned earlier I
think is one of one of the great
challenges
ahead of us uh they need it in the
workplace and working from home is not
good for young people to get on and so
yeah I do think I do think that uh it's
good to see actually some 2019 Red Bull
Tory MPS who come from working class
backgrounds but I do think the class
divide in this country is set in stone
far more than a level was the
opportunities to break out of it out
there you know world wars ironically
gave people from Humble backgrounds a
chance to move up through the ladder
grammar schools for example gave a lot
of people from those backgrounds the
chance to Excel and go up the ladder and
I do ever so slightly feel that middle
class Britain has pulled the drawbridge
up
so I I have been a little bit thinking
about this
question birth rate
Global birth rates declining in all
developed Nations
and Elon Musk has been talking about
this recently so I do think we have been
talking about it but prior to him
and and also someone like Matthew
Iglesias in his book one billion
Americans talks about this
which is just it seems to be close to a
law of
of
um
I don't know what you would call it
developmental economics or or what have
you that as societies become wealthier
and more educated people stop having
enough children to replace their numbers
naturally
um
and you see it in pretty much everywhere
on earth and the only places you don't
see it
are either societies that are that
haven't become wealthy yet
or the highly religious the ultra
ultra-orthodox Jews the uh the Amish men
and Mennonites
um you know the Amish in America have
more than doubled their numbers in since
the 90s which is incredible right while
the rest of America has receded below
replacement level
and and what happens when you don't use
condoms mate it's more happens when you
don't have entertainment mate yes
what else are you gonna do yeah
but it's interesting to think about the
the long-term
future of humanity right like if
everyone what we want to happen is that
poor countries
stop being poor like poor countries we
want that to happen so let's say that
happens and everywhere on earth now is
replaced it was below replacement level
except for
the ultra religious
minorities that are doubling their
numbers every 10 years what a great
recipe for a future world it's
interesting to think about what world
that creates yeah
I'm sure they want maybe a vision mate
no it'll be fine maybe it's not a big
problem maybe it's such a slow-moving
emergency that the equilibrium will
shift and you know it's kind of not
something to worry about but
Maybe
I don't know maybe it changes the
fundamental fabric of society if you
have like what
40 percent of America's Amish in like
the year 3000 or something if America
still exists
well is it one thing that we're not
talking about as a society that we
really should be talking about
big one
it's pedophilia and the erosion of
safeguarding towards children
we're not [ __ ] leaving it there tell
us a little bit about what what you
actually mean by that I think there was
uh along with this trans wave and I'm
not going to conflate the two because
that's not remotely what I'm saying
however if I was a pedophile
and I was watching with Glee at the
severance of family control and autonomy
like in the schools in Birmingham and
what our children primary school age
children are being taught the fact that
if you're a man you can go away with the
Girl Guides now and they don't have to
tell your parents the parents of the
children
and the sex sort of the way we talk
about sex in schools and then
pornography and the way that that's
easily accessible for children and it
all just
it's really uncomfortable I feel like
I'm wearing some sort of fall hat and
should be on the David Ike show instead
of this very sensible and reasonable
show but it does feel that there's some
really uncomfortable things happening
with the erosion of of boundaries
this is something that people will not
talk about that there is a
methamphetamine epidemic among gay men
that is killing large numbers of gay men
uh it is the most hideous drug it is
taking people's lives away it's away
uh it is rampant
uh no one talks about it
certainly the gay press barely talks
about it
uh it's implicated in a whole bunch of
things
uh that you can see I mean for example
it's the real story of Matthew Shepard
not that he was assaulted by two
complete redneck strangers of hated gays
but he was assaulted by his own
boyfriend
who was on meth for five days
um that makes much more sense of
situation than than these other things
and and but the ability and the need to
suppress this reality because it's dirty
laundry
because it's telling the truth about
problems that we have it's not helping
gay men either
um and I really would like to see this
treated with seriousness it deserves
um Andrew why is it happening I have not
heard about this at all I don't know if
you have friends you have uh well maybe
you're more informed than I am but why
is it happening why is it specifically
in the gay community
it's a good question because there are
other communities for example in America
it's very much a sort of um working
class white rural epidemic as well
um it's just it's it's used in
conjunction with sex it's apparently a
fantastic sort of uh uh experience
temporarily when you're on this thing
you feel great and powerful and all the
rest of it you have you have sex for
days on end
um
and people talk about that experience as
a super wonderful and they can't go back
to having sex without it I eat
I've just seen it destroy people
friends
and and and and it goes on everyone
acknowledges it privately it reminds me
of the early days of AIDS in which
people refuse to actually acknowledge
because they were scared that the facts
of the matter would alienate people from
gay people uh well we are alienating
ourselves we are committing suicide in a
way as a community
and you can barely see a word written
about it
um and and I think again it's probably
the media's attempt
well meant but Howard cowardly
not to wear dirty laundry about
minorities when in fact that dirty
laundry needs to be aired in order to
help minorities in order to have
minorities help themselves
um so for example denying that in
America that
terrible toll of violence on black
people is something that is a function
of white supremacy when it is clearly a
function of of criminals killing them uh
uh is an important thing to remember
um infinitely more
the black Americans are killed by
civilians and by cops and yet we barely
mention the former we obsess on the
latter and I'm not saying that killing
by cops is something we should not be
concerned about we should but the
spectacles is all skewed similarly
in terms of where gay people are instead
of talking about the hatred other people
have for us which they generally don't
except for a few Nutters uh let's talk
about how we can take care of ourselves
what issues of self-esteem are still
buried within us the things that that
makes it preferable to go on these drug
Benders and just get on with your life
building a relationship or setting up a
home or or getting a productive career
going
um it happens to be a very potent drug
too which seems to hook people very
quickly and be incredibly hard to
recover from
um it has taken a real toll and still
going on well there are lots of things I
would have I would certainly have talked
about the the Cannabis issue if we
hadn't already done so but it isn't
talked about anything like enough and
the the correlation between cannabis use
and mental health cannot be taught about
enough because it's and the current the
correlation between cannabis use and
crime cannot be talked about enough
because they are major problems I'm
pursuing a petition on this matter at
the moment to try and get the government
to inquire into the link to see if it is
not just a correlation but a genuine
causal connection but the other thing
that that's always preoccupies me and
has preoccupied me since my childhood is
the horrible way in which we allow the
car to dominate our civilization it's it
I have chosen to make it the dominant
means of transport and will not turn
away from this so even now near where I
live in Oxford there's a plan for yet
another Motorway called the Oxford
Cambridge Expressway which will be a a
horrible scar across the face of the
country will solve no problems but it's
based upon this this love of an
obsession with the car as the only
modern means of Transport we're prepared
to give serious support to which does so
much damage to health to to the beauty
of the country to town planning to the
way in which people live in indeed to
the freedom of children to roam about
the countryside it's the car it's not
it's not uh pedophile killers they exist
and when they and when they happen
they're terrible things and I I'm not
laughing about that they do exist but
it's very rare but the real danger the
real reason why children can't roam
about is that when I was young is
because the roads are just too dangerous
and we just tolerate this and the large
numbers of deaths and terrible injuries
every year holy innocent people and
nobody cares I really do wish people
cared more about it it's it's uh it's
it's it's done a great deal of damage
and we can do a lot more to restrain it
and do you think that would that would
be the case we could we could do more to
restrain if the public transport system
was better and more efficient well in
Zurich and Switzerland is a paradise of
Railways in public transport you can get
anywhere in Switzerland without a car in
Switzerland in Zurich they made the tram
system so good that people gave up
driving their Mercedes I want that to
happen here I want the public transport
system to be so good to people no longer
want to use cars and I I think it would
be a huge improvement in our in our way
of life as it was done
this is going to be a controversial one
I don't know if I should really say it
but we're not talking about the great
reset we're not talking about build back
better this hashtag that's taken over
the world and I'm not a conspiracy
theorist but there is something going on
here I don't want to leave this horrible
pandemic this horrible lockdown a
different country I want the old normal
I don't want a new normal you know I
don't want to come out of this in a
cashless Society
and I'm very worried about all the
things that I'm hearing
um from our government about hashtag
buildback better I'd like us to return
if we want a better Society we can work
on it together we don't want it
implemented for us or on us that is
oppression that is tyranny all right
well in for a penny in for a pound since
you've brought it up I mean I think the
monetization went when you said house
negro about 73 times in a row uh but
just when you said it then as well yeah
uh but since you bring it up look I
don't know what the great reset is
someone sent me the link to the world
economic Forum I looked on it it just
looked like a bunch of people who are
like oh we want to to end capitalism or
whatever which is fine people are
allowed to want to earn capitalism I
don't agree with it right but when you
talk about the great reset what are you
talking about look at the way he's got
his hand over his mouth I'm not a
conspiracy theory but 5G
and lizard people lizard people yeah
well it's this idea that you will own
nothing and you will be happy that
really disturbs me and it's not even
again capitalism is a new form of
capitalism it's this idea that so we're
seeing it already for example I went to
my bank to pay in a check the other day
right and it's so difficult to do that I
I tried to queue up the cashier there's
only one there they encourage you to go
use the machines I'm a computer
scientist I'm not a Luddite but
I don't like everything being automated
because we're losing what we're actually
seeing is the Erasure of the working
class so normal jobs that normal people
would do are now being automated
but that doesn't stop the wealthy still
earning money so what we're seeing is
the cost divide is widening people who
are already rich and successful and
Powerful will remain so but their normal
ordinary folk who did normal ordering
jobs their jobs won't exist very soon
and we're seeing covert being used as a
cover to speed up the process we you
know for example the 45 pound cash limit
on contactless payments been increased
to 100 pound to increase
um to improve the economy how does that
improve the economy but is that not
quite a conspiratorial thing to say
because you say used as a cover it's
perfectly credible in my view to say not
used as a cover but it's like if we're
paying for if we're trying to reduce the
number of physical contacts so people
can spread disease
doing things contactless sort of makes
sense just as a counter argument that
would be one of the things right the
other thing you talk about the the you
know Erasure of the working class I get
that completely but it's been already
happening it's pretty much if you listen
to Andrew Yang why Donald Trump got
elected right automation is taking over
people's jobs is that really like people
are using covid nefariously or is it
just like what's happening it's not
nefariously but they're using it to
speed up the process so why would you
open your branches so it costs you x
amount to employ so many people when you
can just have a machine that you put
your check into and you know you save
yourself a lot of money so people are
using covid now when we come out of it
we won't have the same society that we
went into it with that's the problem and
you know I'm really not conspiratorial
but the problem I have with the world
economic forum and this this great reset
is that it's all there in the open and
it is you know the Davos
um conference that all the world leaders
go to all the most rich and powerful
people in the world go to and they're
not conspiring behind our backs but
they're talking about this very openly
this idea that they want to change
society want to improve it but it's in
their image it's not Democratic we're
we're not having a discussion about this
it's being put on us and that's what
that's what scares me that's what
worries me and even raising the issue
makes you look like a tinfall hat
wearing you know swivelite Loom which I
am but not because of this
I'll be honest with you I do think
they're using it as a way to get rid of
cash and I don't buy the whole oh less
contact well you've just got one Central
disease Vector which is a chip and pin
yeah well who benefits from us having
less cash well the government because
they can track you know because they can
track us more effectively and number two
it's it's a way to control Working Class
People who pay using cash indeed but
also what I worry about in the long run
is you know systems like what they have
in China if you do or say the wrong
thing your your social credit is
destroyed we say no nothing like that
would ever happen in this country but
talk to me a year ago this time a year
ago I never would have thought we'd lock
down citizens in their homes and tell
them who they're allowed to invite into
their own house I would have thought
that would be a completely foreign idea
so you never know where we're going to
be in in a year's time never mind 10
years time that's what petrifies me
about this whole thing well I think
we're talking about the death of Common
Sense and the centralization of the
marginal so that what you get is a
marginal phenomenon taking over our
taking over our imagination completely
so that for example a good example is
transsexualism what comes next is the
interesting question oh hello hello and
what do you think what do you think is
coming next I think it'll be incest
explain
I think incest will be permissible
soon because there's no logical argument
against it
you don't have to have children
so two consenting adults quote unquote
exactly go for it
there will be celebrations up and down
corner
hey KK Do You Believe In Spring cleaning
yes but only when my wife does it in
Russian men who clean up executed for
not being real men which is correct well
for those men who are living in the 21st
century manscape has an incredible offer
for you manscaped are the global leaders
immense below the waist grooming and
have forever changed the grooming game
with their amazing performance package
4.0 inside this care bundle you'll find
their lawnmower 4.0 trimmer weed whacker
ear and nose hair trimmer crop preserver
ball deodorant crop reviver toner
performance boxer brief and a travel bag
to hold your goodies this Elite trimmer
is designed to trim hair on loose skin
although your werewolves might look like
a couple of Boris Johnson's treat them
with respect and benefit from their
proprietary skin safe technology
complete your grooming game this spring
with the new refined cologne signature
scent by manscaped this stuff is legit
and we'll have you smelling like royalty
the good kind not prince Andrew get 20
off and free shipping with the code
trigger 20 at manscape.com that's 20 off
and free shipping with the code trigger
20 at manscape.com it's time to throw
out all your old hygiene habits and
upgrade your life
what's the one thing we're not talking
about as a society but we really should
be
uh I think it's Constantine's baldness
foreign
I'm glad I brought it up now because it
really isn't being mentioned enough
yeah
absolutely I don't think we talk about
it enough we should we should talk about
it more sure
we should in fact we should talk about
it outside the scope of trigonometry
because this custom trigonometry quite a
lot but I think we need to broaden out
the conversation Antony's our producer
Anton darling could you turn that into a
meme please
I don't know the population problem I
gotta go to that again I mean I feel
like that's going to solve a lot of
[ __ ] problems we talked about that
before the podcast started so give us
give us give it give it to us again
what's the population problem Bill well
there's too many goddamn people that's
that's the whole like all these
inventions and all of this [ __ ] are nice
but if there's too many people around
using them so you got to figure out a
way
without becoming a mass murderer to get
people to to die yeah well like it
annoys me when I watch the news and you
just see these weather man going I'll
tell you it's gonna be a hot one and
it's like how do you not how do you do
that job as a [ __ ] weatherman I feel
like there's two kinds of weathermen the
people who are actually [ __ ] paying
attention to that [ __ ] and then the
other person who just wanted to get on
TV so they have a hot [ __ ] wife you
know what I mean and I see those like
the LA weatherman you got to watch watch
the local news like the [ __ ] La
weatherman they just sit there like you
know you know tonight it's gonna be
cloudy when we get back in these crazy
jackets on the [ __ ] I mean I love it
because they're like entertaining but
like it's like dude you look like you're
selling cars and I just think that's
such a funny personality to have
while all of this end of the world [ __ ]
you know Lakes are drying up and all
this is too [ __ ] terrifying to talk
about so
animal rights
yeah I'm sorry I'm I'm
so sorry I'm really really dull on
animal rights they're gonna have to cut
this
um I think animal rights are is one of
the biggest things are the two things
there's rights for Working Class People
who I don't class in the same group as
animals
myself I thought about making that joke
but I was like I better not but you did
it
um so it's two things I think we need
identity politics for the working class
and I also think we need to uh I think
we need to clamp down on the abusive uh
animals race for food and if anyone ever
suggests bringing back a fox hunting
bill they should actually be shot
through the head of the kind of bolt gun
or a rail gun
if you see the new rail guns
um so those two things those those are
the two things so you think we need
identity politics for the working class
rather than just moving away from
Identity politics in general I was a bit
a bit flippant by and large that's the
one identity which is never ideal no it
isn't it isn't but my point is I think
we need to remove identity Politics as a
thing sure right of course you do yeah
of course you do you do on economics
yeah yeah I just think one concern for
me with identity politics is it pushes
people who are not represented by it
into their own identity and then you
suddenly get you know 10 million
straight away men going oh yeah well we
are discriminating against because we're
straight away men that's not going to
end very well no but that'll happen well
that's my point that will happen which
is why I don't think
it's actually a quote from Morris uh
when a Morris Glassman um he says you
know the labor party has all this
identity politics but none of it about
the people it was set up to represent
yeah and that that's roughly where I'm
from which is why you should vote for
the social Democrats
that can is not on me is it it's
probably enough
can I have a drink now yeah well
we're not talking about dads and the
importance of dads I think you know we
sit around and we kind of Chase problems
like what's going on with all this
street crime what's going on with the
failing school systems you know what's
going on with all the substance abuse or
you know homelessness or suicide you
know prison overcrowding you know we
were kind of like
who are all these people in prisons you
know and then we do this thing where we
go
we need to either build more prisons or
just let the people out who are in
prison and my thing is is why don't we
find out why they're in prison like
maybe that's maybe that's something you
know what I mean like we have two
choices and my feeling is like maybe
there's a third choice which is like
where are their dads and what roles do
they play in their life and what the
hell happened
and dads are super important we somehow
decided that they were part of the
problem there's like toxic masculinity
or some nonsense they're not they're
vitally important we got in some weird
world where like she's a single mom and
she's doing her best and we applaud it
and no one goes where's the Dad where's
Dad we decided
that there didn't really have a role or
as an important role as they did in the
past everything we see is just an
offshoot of broken families absent dads
and bad parenting and were fools just to
chase it around like this guy he's 16.
he shot one guy then he went into the
system then he got let out then he
punched this woman in the pushed her
onto the tracks at the subway then he
got arrested again then he was out on
the street that afternoon it's like all
right we can follow that one kid around
it's costing us millions of dollars
because it gets into the system and so
on and so forth or we can try to go back
a little further and figure out where
the dad is how come the dad didn't raise
him correctly how come he didn't
discipline him out all the things you
get from that we could do that
politicians never do that
because that's like a third rail that
starts breaking down along racial lines
and and it turns into a nightmare so
they talk about
the problem which is essentially
the damage that the termites do but they
never talk about eradicating the
termites or how they got in the house or
whatever it is so they're just like it'd
be like if an exterminator just chased
around ants and hit him with a slipper
individually it was like where's the
colony where are they coming from what
are they attracted to well they're like
moisture good you have a leaky pipe fix
the pipes they're attracted to the
moisture you know we're not we talk
about like root causes all the time we
never get to the root of everyone goes
why is there so much violence what's
going on this 15 year old boys punching
people on the subway it's like yeah
we're asked these guys where their dads
are go go to prison and find out
everyone's relationship with their dad
okay that's the problem that would fix
all the other problems around
we'll never we never talk about it
that's why we love Larry Eldon that's
why we had him on the show he's very
good on that but I'm really glad that
white supremacist
the state is missing a huge opportunity
to use its kind of convening power
combined with the with the digital world
to create to make it so much easier for
people to say volunteer do you kind of
just in time volunteering why don't we
have no there ought to be I mean it
would need to have the states kind of
imprimatur on it and it should be
advertised over on the kind of tube on
the TV that you go to this one portal
and you put you know and you type in
your postcode and you find out
um you know I mean you know a lot of
people that have very busy lives but
they still want to kind of and we've
seen this actually in the pandemic
um you know a huge amount of
volunteering let's try and keep some of
that
um going forward
um you know you should be able to type
in your postcode and then find out you
know it may be little stuff like there's
some little old lady who lives up the
street from you he just needs her drugs
picked up from from boots and you needs
to be taken out for a walk every
you know for an hour every every weekend
or something and the little things that
you could sort of fit in around you know
even if you have a family and you're
very busy
um and of course one of one of the
issues I guess would be security
um uh and there's ways to do all of that
but exactly it's interesting how the
whole kind of um child protection thing
you know seems to be suspended for the
for for covert volunteering
um but I think you know and that and
that could be applied to other things
too I mean another thing actually sorry
related thing that I've always had to be
in my Bonnet about is
um and I'm not going to go into a whole
Germanic Spiel I mean I I am very nicely
with the reputation of the show
the banner behind me
but I did spend three years in Germany I
know the German system well and and a
lot of things about it to admire and a
lot of those things cannot very easily
be translated into into the British
context but one thing that could very
easily be is there's something called
the beroof actual that all kids who
leave school get I think particularly
the kids who are going on to an
apprenticeship it essentially tells them
what all the kind of the options are for
apprenticeships and what the jobs that
you could then
you could then apply for once you'd got
this apprenticeship
and what they pay and and so on and I
don't see why why don't we have
something like that in the UK just you
know again it's something the state
would need to do would have to have the
kind of impromature of a and you know
you could update it every year and it
could have not only here are all these
all these different jobs and this is
what they pay and this is what this is
the training you need in order to get it
you know so you know a coding course is
going to cost you five grand what
subsidy might you be able to get from
the state to do it you know why isn't it
all just written in one place I mean you
can probably find out it's probably it's
all out there somewhere but it's kind of
it's in it it's it's all it's scattered
everywhere we should just you know this
is a perfect example of what the state
ought to be able to do very simply I
mean you could you know someone at the
DWP ought to be able to do that in kind
of two days just gather all this stuff
together put it in one place produce a
little booklet for it or have it online
and update it every year and I think it
would make it would make the whole sort
of feel particularly now with so much
uncertainty you make it would create so
much more visibility and transparency
for for people in this very uh unsure
situation
your capacity
to be offended
is not something that anyone need or
should respect in you like that's just
not
it's not an argument certainly not an
argument but it's not even a basis for
respect like that like table Stakes for
any ethical conversation
he is more than just your capacity to be
offended right and
um
until you understand that like you're
just not
you you
can't play the game we need to play in
order to to ensure an open-ended
circumstance of cooperation
I'm gonna I'm going to introduce
something now which you might find a
little bit uncomfortable
um in the book I wrote right about a
time that I was nearly raped and I
didn't really think anything about
writing this because it it didn't
traumatize me at the time and it doesn't
traumatize me now
um but the Observer rang me up and so
they they were doing an article on a TV
series called I will destroy you as a
male rape scene in that so they said can
we do an interview with you about this
so I spent about half an hour on the
phone to them and the article wasn't
about that at all it was just about me
which was a bit of a shock in a way
um
so I then did a phone in on it and I'll
be see the following night for two hours
and the number of men that phoned in say
yeah this happened to me well it either
happened to me or nearly happened to me
or my mate or whatever
and I do think this is something that
Society doesn't really talk about we've
got a lot we've had a lot of taboos in
society and this is kind of one of the
last ones I think
12 000 men were raped last year
um I think only about a thousand of the
cases ever got to court I don't know how
many
um actually were convicted
uh the average how long do you think it
takes
for a man who has been a victim of a
sexual assault whether it's by and often
it's actually a straight male that is
doing it
um really yeah how long does it take for
a man to tell anybody about it on
average I'm gonna guess like 20 years 26
years yeah wow now you think of the
mental health aspects oh whereas
somebody's bottling up inside and I know
several people that this has happened to
in just in my sort of Circle of contacts
and I think well if I know sort of
there's probably four or five
what about the ones that I don't know
and you think well this this is
something that needs to be addressed and
there's a charity called survivors UK
which I've now kind of adopted and sort
of if I give money to charity they they
get it because I think this is a really
big issue that I mean people don't want
to talk about for obvious reasons it's a
very uncomfortable subject but it's also
I mean there's also
um again I've I've the day one of the
national newspaper commissioned me then
to write a long read feature on it which
in the end they decided not to run which
I was a bit annoyed about because I
spent a lot of time writing it
researching it so I've actually put it
on my website now
um
uh and I I just think that it's
something that people need
to understand that it happens and it's
not just men on men it's actually women
on men as well bizarrely I mean okay
it's slightly more difficult for a woman
to rape a man but there is a lot of
um I mean if we just think of the sort
of me too things about sort of male
employers groping female staff or making
inappropriate comments to them
um I remember back in the 1990s where I
was
um
I mean a woman that I worked with just
grabbed my crotch
now imagine if I as a man did that to a
woman that didn't traumatize me at all I
just said do you think that's
appropriate
um momolam when she was Northern Ireland
secretary at a labor Party Conference
she had a picture taken with me and my
partner we were running the bookstore
and she stood in the middle of us put
her arms around us and started kneading
our buttocks
that's sexual assault all right again I
didn't I thought it was quite funny at
the time but in today's environment
you can't call it anything else
so there's so many issues around this
that I think we shy away from talking
about so that's very long way to answer
to your question no but it's a very good
answer and if anyone I'm sure there will
be people in our audience who
unfortunately have had this sort of
experience survivors survivors UK
survivors UK and I mean have a read the
article it's on iondel.com and I mean I
literally had dozens of people
contacting me on Twitter about it and
saying well I thought I was the only one
and you can understand why well the UK's
most prolific rapist was actually a man
who wrote young men absolutely right
well that's a nice way to end yeah yes
very as ever yeah my answer to that is
really mundane
well it's not that we're not talking
about it I don't think we talk about
climate change enough
I feel like
in 10 years it's going to be at the
point where we're wondering why we were
talking about woke racism Etc when the
planet was about to burn up I really
worry about that but you want something
more underground than that
um I mean to be fair with you John in
this country we talk about climate
change an awful lot I promise you that
yeah I mean it's not that it's not
talked about I sometimes worry that
we're all going to think we should have
talked about it even more but what do we
not talk about
um
I wish
that science were more interested
in finding a cure for clinical
obesity
because I feel like it wouldn't be that
hard
given what can now happen it's not
considered as important as some other
things and I guess I understand why but
I watch people who
have that condition and often it's not
because they eat too much or sometimes
it is but you can't stop eating too much
and I think to myself wow I would hate
to be that person I don't think that
it's their fault
and I wish that there were a more
concerted solution to that I think about
it all the time I'm not sure why obesity
has never been a personal problem of
mine but watching the way people eat and
the way people in
non-western countries are beginning to
eat the same way that that seems to be a
way people start eating when Prosperity
comes in watching what's happening in
some parts of China or on some
Polynesian Islands I know that seems
like an eccentric thing that I'm just
kind of bringing up to sound fresh but
it has
always touched me deeply that people end
up
ruining their bodies through no fault of
their own because of the way food is in
modern societies I wish that could be
solved that is my honest answer to the
oh boy
um it's gonna be really heavy okay yeah
yeah abortion
okay yeah I think that needs some more
serious discussion I think it's the
biggest blight on society and I think a
real serious discussion and elevation of
consciousness is needed around it so to
make that more specific for us I'm
guessing given that you're religious
you're probably against abortion yeah
not from a religious basis but okay I am
against it yeah yeah
um I mean you've got those are human
lives and thousands are being taken
every day and it's very much out of
sight out of mind and it's certainly not
a dinner table party conversations up
that anyone wants to get into but um the
way I look at it is very similar to how
I imagine the people who wanted to
abolished slavery would have felt like
hundreds of years ago and you've you've
got this thing that everybody accepts
and has been going on for thousands of
years and people aren't questioning it
and it's deemed as a you know slavery
was always deemed from the perspective
of the slaveholders rights right we have
a right to do this we have a right to do
this
um abortion generally in the western
world is very much framed as from
pro-choice people of course as a women's
rights issue right and very little very
few people ever think about
the baby
Venus if you want to if you want to you
know use the use the euphemism and it's
it's all it's completely framed in that
regard not from pro-life people pro-life
people are like um what about the baby
that's being killed right but um I think
that they're
I think that that whole conversation I
don't know if society's yet mature
enough to have that conversation but
it's a conversation that I do think is
is needed like it's something that
troubled me something that troubles me
every day genuinely it troubles me it
troubles me a lot not because it
directly impacts Me by just knowing
the rates of it you know looking at the
numbers I mean in some parts of the US I
mean black babies in particular have a
50 50 chance of being aborted okay so
over 50 million potential Americans have
been killed since uh in the past like 40
years or something like that I don't
know the exact figures in the UK but um
considering how
far we've come in a society in terms of
just like Consciousness and treating
people decently and humanely and stuff
like that that one does trouble me to
know that the most vulnerable members of
the human species
are not even
considered in those things and I know
it's it's a very polarizing topic it's
something people get very heated on
understandably on both sides
um but um yeah in terms of a societal
blind spot or something people just
don't want to don't want to touch don't
want to talk about I do think that it's
uh to me personally it's a it's
something serious yeah I think the thing
with that is that I it's such a
difficult issue because I don't think
it's about maturity I'm not sure that
issue is ever going to get resolved
we're never going to find like a
solution because it's kind of halfway
and there's always going to have to be a
compromise and when you're talking about
human lives compromises don't really
make that's the problem yeah this is the
problem that's the thing yeah so I guess
I feel like the place we're at now
is it's in this country is kind of as as
good a compromises you're probably going
to get uh then again you know the human
lives and these are these are people and
so we're talking about not everybody
even accepts that a lot of people don't
yeah but that's that's only because
they're bullshitting themselves because
they don't want to have the real they
don't want to go we're killing people
yeah but of course but maybe we we
should be allowed to sometimes you know
like that's really the compromise we're
at yeah because it's kind of halfway it
is a woman's rights issue it is a a
woman's righteous on the one hand on the
other hand it is killing people and you
have to be able to hold both of those in
your head yeah and be okay with that and
that's very difficult to do yeah and
most people don't even accept what you
just said yeah right most people who are
pro-choice would either try to say that
that's not a human life or they just
that's nonsense yeah but well it ha
there's millions of people who hold that
position you know I think they're just
trying to defend their arguments yeah no
I think so too I think so too because at
least that's an honest position if
someone again you have to at least put
the facts on the table yeah you know put
the facts on the table again you know
and my argument is not from a religious
standpoint at all it's not religious at
all it's just saying you know do you
believe that it's wrong to kill innocent
human beings yeah 99 of people will say
yes yeah okay most people will accept it
stabbing a newborn baby is wrong and you
should go to prison for it okay but a
lot of people think that until that baby
comes out you can chop it up yeah right
so you can stab it as long as it's still
in the womb you can stab it and I'm like
how does that make sense yeah okay so
for me uh this is something that a few
people are talking about but in my
opinion one that not nearly enough
people are talking about which is
uh uh the fact that our cities are
growing increasingly ugly
I.E that
for every beautiful new building that is
constructed
19 or 20 ugly buildings are constructed
and indeed uh one of the few people who
has been making the case for beautiful
architecture so Roger scrutin was
recently fired from his role as a
government advisor on this matter
following a sort of hit job in the new
Statesman
and so I think many many more people
need to be talking about the fact that
we need
physical Beauty in our lives and that
much of it has been taken away from us
at least in the UK over
um the last few decades
and that it's a sort of it's a public
good it's the most important public good
in society that no one or only people
like sir Roger scrutin and a few others
want to talk about we obviously
recognize or many people believe that
the Health Service is a really valuable
public good in society
uh many people believe that education
and the natural environment are
important public goods but no one seems
to or very few people seem to mention
that the beauty of the streets who walk
down going to work or on the way to the
shops are also public good and we should
um yeah fight to defend that public good
against
uh encroachments of of increasing
ugliness
well I mentioned conservatives then
conserve
um and uh recording this in the week
when Extinction Rebellion returned to
the streets and I think that um
extension Rebellion isn't adequately a
rebellion against extinction because I
think
um both on the left and the right we are
ignoring the the detail of what is
happening in this country's country this
Britain's Countryside which is that we
are as a people the most nature loving
people anywhere if you judge it by a
number of people who belong to Wildlife
Conservation Charities and yet we have
the most ecologically denuded landscape
in Europe
um we cannot lecture people much poorer
countries on their need to conserve
wildlife when we are
allowing
um hedgehogs to plummet towards
Extinction when our rivers are being
poisoned when uh songbirds are Vanishing
and this was a topic that people briefly
woke up to during the lockdown when
suddenly there was no traffic and people
could hear Birdsong and people realized
they valued and and wanted it
um
but now that
um uh blood is returned to the limited
economy that sense that we share this
country with other species
and that in a sense we're trust holders
for them is fading again
and I think that that's what we should
be talking about I think that that there
is an Extinction crisis but I think that
talking about it in the broad brush
terms that Extinction Rebellion do
misses the fact that we need to
concentrate on specifics you're talking
about conservationism
yeah I'm talking about
um the need for a mass National effort
to say for instance to stop hedgehogs
from going extinct
prime minister I would write it into law
that um there's an obligation on the
government to reverse the training
Hedgehog numbers and hedgehogs repel
weather species if you reverse them then
you reverse other things as well you
have to put in you know you have to
improve the environment for hedgehogs to
survive you have to make sure they're
insecture everything follows from that
that's what I would do that to me is
a terrible pressing issue that we don't
talk about nearly enough and it seemed
like a kind of you know uh gimmicky
theme it doesn't really matter but to me
it's fundamental
we're not talking enough about sex
speak for yourself
I I don't know if you guys have seen but
there was this crazy chart that came out
a few months ago that showed that and
this was before covid that the
percentage of men in America between the
ages of 18 and 24.
who hadn't had sex in the previous year
I think was 30 percent
that's wild to me and that's a story
that I feel like has not been told and
has incredible cultural and political
ramifications so I'll be looking it's a
story that's very much on my radar
um because the question of like are we
turning into Japan I think is and and
what are the implications of that I
think are a really interesting one
the ladies of trigonometry you've got a
job to do
the last question we ask and this is
going to sound funny given what you've
just said is what's the one thing
bad not bad
it's been a long day dude you ask him
the question yeah okay so Theo the last
question we always ask is what's the
thing
[Music]
is this mirror this is a good mirror
yeah it is a good mirror did this chain
be out the whole time oh no it's good
all right what's the one thing we're not
talking about that we really should be
um
[Music]
I think they
oh dude I remember one time I saw these
massive Birds right they call them in
Europe yeah it's beautiful strong
uh
I swear bro I went to this I went to
this place called Newcastle have you
heard of this yes yeah Newcastle and
this taxi drops me off and there was
these it was like a part like a
I'm supposed to look like a bachelorette
party or something and and this foyer of
like a big there was a big room like a
big window and they were in there naked
you know what do you call it
tits yes yes tits
and they were beating each other with
pillows in there bro and I sat out there
and watched smoked a cigarette out there
right out there and that's the one thing
no one's talking about huh and that's
the one thing I was talking about there
was seven of these women in there
I can see why you brought it up it was
serious man oh
sounds fantastic well Theo
it was serious bro see I can't even do
it justice because you can't even
believe that it could happen could you
how who would get
him in naked and have them pillow fight
in front of a big huge pitcher window so
it was thought they wanted to be seen
for you I don't know man that's [ __ ]
that's beautiful bro
hey Francis what do you think is the
best way to advertise a business that's
easy all you need to do is spend shed
loads of cash on an advert that's going
to be promoted on a dying medium-like TV
then simply sit back and watch all your
hard-earned money disappeared down the
toilet what about advertising with
trigonometry why would I do that when I
can advertise on itv3 for the measly sum
of 20 grand and be watched by six people
because trigonometry now has over 350
000 subscribers across the different
platforms and gets 2 million views and
downloads a month that's right you can
place an advert with us and we'll
promote your brand on one of our
episodes your advert will be written by
two professional comedians yeah that's
right we're hiring two professional
comedians
when we make our ads funny and engaging
to the point where some people say the
ads are their favorite parts of the show
yeah we probably shouldn't admit that
mate all you need to do is contact us on
marketing at
triggerpod.co.uk that's marketing a
triggerpod DOT Co dot UK advertise with
us and we'll get your business canceled
what's the one thing we're not talking
about that we really should be well you
should be talking about my books
having fun
and we made it all so serious I mean one
of the things that sustained me in all
of this is I've been I've been attacking
simple pleasure seeking but one needs to
enjoy life
I love doing this I love debate I love
the pleasures of food and drink in the
days when they're more readily available
I love the pleasures of sex and it it
but it's not that destructive Hedonism
that just complete repetition it is the
enjoyment the savoring it I you know
good food drink and decent Furniture
things that are beautiful the the we
were talking about art all of that these
are the things that again using very
unfashionable language elevators take us
Beyond ourselves but can also unite us
with other people
I run a think tank called The Copenhagen
consensus where we look at the world's
big problems and how we can smartly fix
them and and and what we never talk
about are all these other issues we
briefly mentioned in the interview right
the fact that people die from easily
curable infectious diseases that we
don't have good education that we have
terrible Health that we have all these
other problems remember about 300 000
women die in childbirth every year and
2.1 million kids die in in their first
month of life and we know how to fix all
of these problems and often very very
cheaply so my day job is actually trying
to point out all these other great
things that we can do at very low cost
that could help Humanity enormously and
as you might have surmised nobody cares
a little bit in the in the in the third
world right but this is not sexy but
when you can you know sort of run to the
next hurricane that just hit the US and
say global warming that it is a problem
but some way somehow we have lost track
of what really matters and what are the
important things you know if you look at
what is the most environmentally
damaging what a problem what kills most
people not global warming the World
Health Organization estimate about 150
000 people die from global warming every
year and I I would dispute that but we
could get into that no it's the seven
million people who die from indoor and
outdoor air pollution now outdoor air
pollution most people know that's
basically a problem of of low
development you need to put scrubbers on
your coal-fired power plants boring but
would help a lot of people indoor air
pollution is the fact that about 3
billion people every year so almost half
this world's population are so poor they
cook and keep warm with dirty fuels like
dung cardboard and wood that's a
terrible way to heat and cook and what
that means is most of these people so 3B
live indoor
window where it's about 10 times more
polluted than it is outdoor in Beijing
we don't hear about that because it's
not sexy so again the thing we don't
talk about are all these other problems
that we could do so much about at very
low cost so you know for instance we
could do something about maternal and
child deaths one pound would save so
many people that you would do about
87 pounds of social good for every pound
spent that's a phenomenal payback
compared to you know for instance
climate change if we do it really
smartly you can get 11 pounds back on
your pound that's still pretty good but
much of our climate policy you pay a
pound for instance in Paris and you get
11 Pence back which is a really terrible
outcome so my job and the thing we don't
talk about is how we prioritize the
entire world not just the thing that
gets to the top of the news
the thing that does bring to mind is uh
is animals is is the treatment of
animals right
um
it's like it they are they are so not
spoken about like the idea so things
like religion things like think things
like that they they get mentioned in in
our in our House of Commons they get
they get brought up in politics it's
like at least on the manifesto animals
are nowhere to be seen right the idea
that we should the idea that we should
be vegan is totally radical right it's
it's this totally radical idea such that
like if you found it even mentioned in a
party's Manifesto you think whoa that's
crazy but what are we talking about here
we're talking about boycotting an
industry that's torturing innocent
creatures right how is that become a
radical thing to do right the reason why
is because people aren't talking about
it people people it's not normalized
when you say that these things are going
on people say well no I'm sure that I
must just be a bad apple you know that
that can't really be happening it's
surely like there'll be regulations in
place you know that kind of thing it's
like no there's absolutely not and the
reason we're not aware of that is
because we're just not talking about it
the moment that we do begin talking
about it as a society is the moment that
it will begin to end because there's no
way once you give it a moment's thought
and you realize what's actually going on
that you can continue to justify it the
only actual justification for the way
that we're treating these animals is
ignorance
and that's a hell of a justification and
it's not one that you're able to make
for yourself because the moment that you
start making it you're no longer
ignorant
um so I think that certainly that it's
obvious to me and I think it will be
obvious to Future societies that in the
same way that we look back on history
and it's full of white dudes and we
think ah where were the women it's like
it's one of those things it's like
clearly you know people weren't people
just weren't like representing them they
just weren't talking about them it's
like we look back and it's quite obvious
to us now right I think it'll be equally
obvious in the future that people will
be like hold on these guys were like
losing their minds over potentially
exiting the European Union
whilst in the time it took between you
know the vote and today
we've sorted what uh
hundreds of billions
of land animals and trillions of sea
animals and future societies will look
back in the way that we look back and
say like
so these guys were like these guys were
like arguing about this political union
well they were literally owning slaves
these people were arguing about these
these weirdly specific issues well
people were on slave ships how could
they possibly have that kind of
cognitive dissonance I think people said
the same thing about us right now how
were they not talking about this how is
this not Front Page News every single
day
um it's just because it's not in the
conversation
the thing that pisses me off or not
pisses me off perhaps well certainly
occasionally pisses me off but I can't
quite work out is why the issue of the
uyghurs in China uh where it's the
largest internment of human beings on
the planet at the moment it's between
two and three million or one in three
million uh uyghurs in um uh camps uh in
xinjiang and
um we've got all sorts of heinous
horrific stories of uh rape and organ
harvesting and uh just the worst
possible things you can imagine and and
it seems to me to be one of the great
atrocities happening right now and
there's certainly a lot of there's been
a decent amount of coverage across the
board and and it is one of those issues
a bit like Hong Kong which which seems
to in this country
be bipartisan in that there's no one
it's not a divisive issue it's
everyone's pretty much on the same page
I mean there are extremes who are
hesitant to criticize China but that I
would say they're the extremes
um uh but the nevertheless and even
though let's say the uyghur issues in
Hong Kong gets a fair amount of press
coverage I don't think it captures the
imagination of uh
my contemporaries uh and and peers and
um
perhaps this is because
uyghur culture is so alien this is
another thing with maybe one of the
reasons why we got so
um the George Floyd captured the
imagination all the way over here and
it's probably about the same similar
distance to how far away the jinjang is
from here is because we're so marinated
in American culture growing up that it
feels like our culture whereas not only
is
is jinjang a remote province of China
which is completely unimaginable
unfathomable to us but China itself even
though it's the biggest country in the
world is is I don't think it's something
we're educated on at all talk about
being Not educated on communism earlier
we're not educated on China I certainly
it wasn't and it's really difficult
because the language is very strange
uh or like very different to us uh
it's a difficult complicated long
history and and so China generally
speaking we I think it's something we
should all be striving to understand
better but the the uighur that specific
ongoing tragedy I think needs more
attention
um and for any guests who are interested
in learning more about the uyghurs I
recommend following rahima mahmut who is
uh in Britain she's a she's a uighur who
she's also a singer um and she does
various performances which we've been
working together putting on cultural
events together in the UK to try and
Enlighten or or try and show us the the
other side about uyghurs that isn't just
the horrible things that happening this
week is what is uyghur culture what is
weaker food there's various uyghur
restaurants across London there's not
many uyghurs in the UK I think there's
about 500 weeks here
um but maybe if we can paint the picture
of who they are and their wonderful
music their wonderful Traditions then uh
so that we can eventually push the need
needle on this horrible heinous
let's see
rape
we think we talk about it a lot because
it's always in the news in one guys or
another but we don't talk about what it
actually is we don't talk about it as an
expression of hatred and control
and sexual entitlement and that's
the conversation that we're missing we
see it as sex we see it as force and
it's actually about neither of those
things and why is that important Julia
I'm asking because I I don't know much
about it why is that distinction so
important because it's so commonplace
that if we think about it as being
committed by monsters who literally
force a Woman by holding a gun to her
head we only look at the most extreme
cases that are very rare and we don't
look at the rape culture in which we
live it's very commonplace ask pretty
much any married woman of a particular
age
I'll ask if she has
if she's had sex with her partner her
male partner recently that she didn't
want to have
you don't call it rape to her or you'll
get a very different answer and she will
tell you yes she's been coerced into sex
and that's pretty much every woman under
the age of 30 that I speak to
it's much more prevalent than we think
and it really isn't the the masked
Marauder carrying a knife breaking into
women's houses that happens but it's
rare
goodness um I feel like that we are
not talking and should be talking more
about the the spinal impacts of binding
and and things about that nature I've
been doing a few videos lately on that
and it's like people talk about the
bindings effects on breasts but I think
that we need to talk about the spine as
if it's like the foot and we need to
recognize that if we're putting 13 year
olds in binders they're going to end up
with with deformations so we need to be
very careful about that
I think we should actually be talking
more about like you know
the toxicness of surrogacy within our
society right now and I think this idea
of of of of the fact of like you know
having your own designing babies and
kind of assuming that everybody has the
right to have a child
it's a bit random but it's not right I
just I really no no there was a show
that I watched a few years ago which um
had these like you know
um like this family that was buying eggs
from like white hot women and then going
to India and just pumping their eggs in
their sperm like these these fetuses
into
um these poor the these poor Indian
women and there are enough kids out
there for us to adopt about this idea of
the fact that we're all doing like
surrogacy as though because it's oh this
is a new way that that technology has
allowed us to have a family it's really
problematic and I think and then again
you can't say that because it's about
certain communities feeling like they're
being there and they're being targeted
but I just think like you know sorics is
a massive issue and I think it's a I
think it's a very
um
under
um like in a research and talked about
form of violence against women
right well I've given that some thought
and I think that what we should be
thinking about and we're not thinking
about
is and not talking about enough
is
um the place of God in society
so it is my belief and it's a a firm
belief of mine that
that
um a belief in God
from a belief in God
flew
the things that a good Society needs we
need an objective morality
which restrains us all from doing things
which though we want to do them are not
good for us
and what I think is required is the
humility
and
it needs humility you need humility
to recognize and accept the belief that
the existence of God
um scientism the belief that science
solves all and that science is in some
ways
our replacement for God will lead us
eventually down terrible blind ally
allies
um we need to we need to ReDiscover
our sense of
um our own
insignificance and ignorance we have to
understand that we don't understand and
we never will understand there are
Mysteries Beyond human comprehension I
think
and um the pretense that in some way
we do fine without God
is a huge mistake so that's what I think
we should talk about
and I think that
one of the things which is which is
tearing the country apart at the moment
is the lack of any unifying
belief system we've got an elite which
believes in nothing beyond what is
concrete and human and materialistic
and that ignores
the experience the entire
experience of humankind from its very
beginning
you know it's striking you go to I
recently went to Mexico
and um I saw these uh huge strange Mayan
temples out in the middle of the jungle
and
I've never been before and I know for a
little about my own culture but the
Striking thing is that everywhere you go
in the world as you see the ancient
structures Notre Dame for instance you
know all these things are built to the
glory of Gods
plural they all they're all an
expression of human belief in God
and actually I don't think we can do
without that
I don't think that I mean we think we
can do without it and atheists are very
chippy and sort of cocky about it you
know we've done with all that crap you
know we don't need that rubbish
um
and uh you know that's not true and
because
in the end the truth of the matter is
uh that that God does exist
and he is a reality or she is a reality
to billions of people in the world
um and that's what a humanist and uh and
the secular don't really take into
account it's an interesting point
because Francis and I are both
non-believers
um but I hear a lot of what you're
saying because I see the effects of
a loss of gun we had Douglas Murray on
the show recently and this is one of the
things that he said he said look I'm a
non-believer but I recognize that we
need something higher than us in order
to keep us in our worst impulses and
check and I also think that
whether it's a belief in God or maybe
just a some kind of
um
maybe secular I don't know but there's
something that comes with the the the
place where you pray that is a community
something that binds you not only in a
broader sense as a society but also bind
you to your nearby community that human
beings absolutely need and without which
we struggle and we wither away and our
mental health has affected and I I'm a
non-believer but I I see that I I can't
ignore that the huge difference that the
emergence of artificial intelligence is
going to make on the battlefield
so military technology with artificial
intelligence is
pushing us logically into where we were
30 years ago with nuclear weapons
it's just that it will be very easy for
us to miss the fact that we've entered a
new paradigm of Destruction before we
unleash it
you know with nuclear weapons we worked
out very quickly that this had achieved
the scale where the disincentive to use
them kicked in
you know generally if we had it we used
it and it kicked in to say ah no maybe
we shouldn't we nearly did we came very
close but we didn't
Artificial Intelligence on the
battlefield is going to the same
Singularity particularly what the
Chinese want to do which is to use
artificial intelligence to mean that
things move too fast for humans to keep
up with to understand what's going on
you know the West is saying we do not
want that to happen we always want a
human decision maker to be the one who
decides whether somebody dies
you do not want AI making that decision
the Chinese is saying well that's for
wuss is the whole power of AI is going
to be that it can think a lot faster
than human beings ever can
and you start to build that into a swarm
of a thousand tiny drones all sorts of
things that that can completely change
the nature of what we think of as a
balance of power in the world as we
understand it at the moment
we should probably be talking about that
a little bit more than we are one issue
I feel very passionate about and resent
that it's never actually discussed in
its own terms is the way that we're
infantilizing our society and the way
that adults are encouraged to behave
like children and the way that children
are adulthified and we kind of that
boundary between adulthood and child is
lost
so what we have is a situation where we
have a lot of biologically mature people
but who are essentially not encouraged
to take themselves seriously and have
that sense of moral and intellectual
Independence that we need and we need
that precisely
for dealing with the challenges that
we've been discussing because this is
very much a grown-up issue and our
children or people who behave childishly
are not going to be in a position
to give a lead or to sort of fight back
against all the bad and negative
developments that are kicking in in our
world
I think it's finding and agreeing on the
place where the left goes wrong
[Music]
and I think it is people
it's been incumbent on people to know
their own ignorance on this
if somebody said to you
what's Auschwitz
that person
is
ignorant
wickedly ignorant
they should not say that
nobody should say that
if somebody said to you
who was Pol Pot
that person is also ignorant in an evil
way
if they don't know
by now
they should know
and we should make sure they know
well you know
we don't have much of a view of what we
want to do
I mean this is a real issue it's like
when I was a kid in the 60s there was
this I read a lot of Science Fiction
there's this sort of technological
Utopia that Bennett beckoned and
everyone was caught up in it post-war
period the better future
well we seem to have exhausted that the
power of that in some fundamental way
where are we headed
why
in some positive manner we're really
stuck on that no political party seems
to be able to formulate it and
and so
what kind of world are we trying to
create and why
that's what we should be talking about
[Music]
[Music]